mein Geheimtipp geht in Richtung offene
Spirituosen also bei uns ist es oft so
dass wir mit einer guten Flasche Wein
kochen oder dass wir mit einer guten
Flasche Wein anfangen und dann ist einem
schon nach ein oder zwei Gläschen hab
man keine Lust mehr und man stellt den
Wein zurück in den Kühlschrank der
Kühlschrank ist ja meistens voll von
Gerüchen und Geschmäckern aus Käse Wurst
und sonst irgendwelchen Geschichten und
wenn man den Wein reinstellt und man
lässt i offen hat man ganz häufig den
Geschmack des kühlschanks im Wein man
hat den Korken schon weggeschmissen
irgendwas anderes inmangung etwas
anderes kriegt man diese Flasche nicht
dazu jetzt gibt's mein Geheimtipp wäre
eine große meistens im Haushalt
vorhandene Weintraube zu nehmen und die
auf die offene Flasche drauf zuulegen
die schließt genau ab mit der Öffnung
der Weinflasche ist praktisch wie
natürlicher Korken das die Flasche wird
bleibt frisch schmeckt ich der
Kühlschrank und wenn man großes Glück
hat ist der Geschmack der Weintraube
sogar noch ein Stück weit dabei wenn man
den Wein demnächsten mal ausschenkt
vielleicht ist das so eine Art
Geheimtipp die euch ein bisschen
weiterhilft